how do you create professional YouTube
videos it's a question I got from one of
my readers Karen great question kind of
a long story but basically wrote I want
to know what setup you use and want to
look as professionals use or when I'm
producing my videos if I can give her
some advice
so Karen great question and it's
something that I struggled with at the
start I hate spending money until I'm
making money and so with any new project
that I'm getting into
I hate dropping cash on something until
I know I'm going to be able to make a
return on it so when I started my videos
if you go back on my channel the videos
sucked the content was pretty good but
the the production quality was not great
it didn't look that professional people
still like looking at them though and
maybe some of you guys watching this
will go back and look at some of the old
videos so I don't like spending a lot of
money once you figured that out then you
have to say how am I going to get
started with it how I started was I use
my first camera so it was a camera that
I already had it was a digital camera I
recorded myself it was on a shelf I had
in my office or at my home and and it
would often shake so it wasn't great
quality I soon you know started to make
some money from what I was doing with
the videos and I figured okay time to
invest back into the company and right
now the setup I use is I have a Sony
camcorder that I bought from Costco I
bought all the cameras that I tested I
went through five cameras over a period
of a couple months because with Costco
you have a 90 day return policy and so
if I didn't like it I could always take
it back one of the main reasons why I
bought this camera was because it has a
microphone jack so I got people watching
the video saying we love your stuff but
the sound quality isn't that great can
you can you improve the sound quality so
I need to get a microphone to do that so
I have this little clip-on mic it's from
Sony that kind of feeds under the shirt
I think it's 80 or 90 bucks that hooks
into the camera I've got a tripod that
that everything sits on so the camera
doesn't shake anymore like you did in
the early videos and I use my phone just
to see what questions I have that have
come up and be able to answer them so
this stuff just pulled up the if you can
see that that you
to question that I got from from Karen
and that's my setup before I had I
tested I having a different background
testing a different lighting if you're
just getting started
really I would recommend starting off
with a decent camera not something
that's too expensive ideally something
you already have or borrow a friend's
camera to get started the microphone
helps with with audio just a quality but
to make it even better think about the
lighting I used to have all sorts of
lights and a background and all that now
I'm just in my office and it's really
important I mean I'm not a video guys
who didn't know this all the other video
guys watching us at all that's common
sense stuff but if you're just going to
start it's important to know you want
the light in front of you so I'm facing
the window so the Sun is hitting me and
I have a solid background behind you
don't want any light behind you and you
don't want light coming at you from the
side if I stood like this and we did my
videos on the side you see like a shadow
on my face or if I did it on a different
angle why don't I show you let's see if
I'm here so this is the rest of my
office if I do it like this the lights
over here you can see that there's light
hitting me here and then it's it's
shadowy here it's dark you can't really
see my face as clearly so you want to be
facing the Sun or facing the light that
you have in your location so set that
back up and here we are again so make
sure you just pay attention line doesn't
cost you anything it just helps make the
video look better okay in terms of the
production I started everything myself
again I didn't like spending money till
I'm making money so I learned how to use
Camtasia and Windows Movie Maker at the
start and now I hired somebody to help
me with my videos and basically I record
the videos I upload them to Dropbox she
downloads them and she'll put the intro
on it put some music put some effects on
it the closing all that stuff that I was
ever really good at and she'll upload
them to my YouTube channel and then I
just have to go in and change the names
of the files and publish so that's been
a really big help but again I didn't
want to do that until I knew I was
committed to the videos so
hopefully that helps I know it's it's
rough and it's scary and it's hard
getting started with video if you're not
used to speak in front of the camera
your first videos will probably suck and
they take tons of takes I remember
taking maybe up to 70 takes on some of
them and they still turn out not great
now it's usually one take if I make a
mistake I just keep going unless the
mistake is right at the beginning
usually just keep going and you get
better you get more confident your
message comes out more clearly and just
start practicing get out there don't be
afraid I know it's it's it's tough and
scary but it can really have a good
impact for people who are coming to your
site but wanting to learn more about you
and the real trick to get started is to
get started and just keep improving and
getting better so thanks for the
question Karen good luck believe send me
your first video when you when you
launch your first one leave it in the
comments I want to see it and maybe I'll
give you some feedback and what you
might be able to do better if everybody
watching if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up below it makes you
want to do more for you and I'd love to
hear what you have to think if you leave
a comment underneath if you're just
getting started with with video as well
or if you have a question for your
business leave it in the comment section
below
I love seeing us come in I'll do a video
response for you and thank you guys I'll
see you soon
you